I find that words really do matter
particularly in our society today where
we're getting a lot of our information
electronically transferred
I think words do matter and I also think
that for whatever reason due to
political correctness or there's a
heightened sensitivity to words you know
you say something oh you're a racist you
reference that person or you reference
that person improperly or you know
there's different ways to describe
people and please I'm probably gonna be
offensive now but but I'm gonna say it
anyway you know when I was a kid you
would say the word oriental if you said
the word oriental today and and you
would be you know excoriated it's
asian-american it was you know forgive
me that Negro when I was a kid
now it's african-american I actually
think the words do matter okay because
at the end of the day you want to be
respectful to other people and again I
hope I didn't offend anybody even by
bringing those up on this I'm just
bringing up the illustration of the
evolution of the words and so so for me
even when you're managing a company you
you have to speak in the right way
because if I say me and my and I I'm
gonna lose the people around me okay
our company is a pronoun usage place of
we and our and team and a commitment to
each other right now this is like a
really silly cliche but you should
really think about if you're running a
company when when the word team is in
your head it's together everyone
achieves more
okay that was from my high school coach
right yeah yet another great aphorism
help the other guy or in the case a bit
help the other girl if there's a gal
okay
his point was don't focus on yourself
but subordinate yourself I watch Derek
Jeter and this is you know I'm gonna
dish a rod for a second year because he
does deserve to be dished a little I
watch Derek Jeter run from the shortstop
position into the bleachers and break
his cheek to catch a foul ball during a
red sock Yankee game while the third
baseman Alex Rodriguez is meandering
okay there's a difference in the two
personalities the one guy is all about
the team could care less about his own
statistics you could care less
about if he's gonna get 3000 hits or not
3,000 he wants to win the World Series
the other guy sitting there looking at a
statistics all day okay so one is very
insular focused and me and I focused and
the other one is we and I'm telling you
right now if you're out there listening
to this thing
you're gonna go way farther in your life
if you can subordinate yourself to the
Wii concept so yes I'm a very big
believer that you have to use the right
words by the way I don't always use the
right words I'm from an italian-american
family we yell and scream at each other
on Sundays I got most of my media
training passing plates of spaghetti as
a kid so so and I also grew up in an
ethnic environment so there were Irish
and Jews and Italians and Welsh and so
we were fighting and sparring with each
other and so I'm not I'm very very far
from perfect
but I think you can really see people's
intentions by the way they talk to other
people and their level of civility